with quick cooking tips know-how and 100
recipes to take your life on now get
ready because this one is all about
cooking for special occasions when
you're cooking for a special occasion
you want to nail some key things one
your recipes need to be bulletproof you
don't want a disaster on the big day two
as well as tasting phenomenal they have
to be easy to serve so you can relax and
enjoy yourself three when you're out to
impress food needs to look great too
my first recipe fits the build perfectly
stuffed Lamb with spinach and pine nuts
stuff meats are perfect for special
occasions they look impressive taste
amazing but more importantly they are so
simple to do
pan on for the stuffing
it's a saddle of lamb basically a sort
of Rolls-Royce cut perfectly shaped and
it suits stuffing it's an absolute tea
for the stuffing finally chop an onion
garlic nice thin slices
oil in
onions and garlic in
it's just salt
and pepper make sure the stuffing is
Juicy seasoned so it helps to season the
inside of the Lamb
now we've got the color on those onions
I'm going to throw in some pine nuts and
that helps to give a bit of a texture
here's where it starts getting really
exciting
spinach in and just lay the spinach over
the pine nuts it looks like a lot of
spinach that's going to condense and
disappear almost instantly
so much more flavor as soon as when you
start it as opposed to steaming it or
boiling it gas off look at that
now to bring that together no eggs no
bread crumbs crumbled feta over the
spinach feta cheese adds a beautifully
salty sharp and creamy flavor
what this does
it brings that stuffing together
now
open up the lamb keep those little
fillets to the side that's the channel
that we want to stuff so I want to just
open that up a little bit there salt
and pepper lightly
and before we put our stuffing in
we're going to season it with
Sumo sumac is a wonderful lemony spice
that goes brilliantly with lamb and you
can get it in most big supermarkets and
it sort of cuts through that thick Rich
sweetness of the Lamb
open up that lamb there
take a spoon if you're preparing this
for the day ahead then let the stuffing
cool down
it's inevitable when you start rolling
it and tying it something's going to
squeeze out so load up the ends
take these Beauties these little fillets
and just support that stuffing and sort
of increase that beautiful tunnel and
then from there
over there
and bring that towards you and then roll
like I said some of the stuff is going
to come out
now I'm going to tie it first off around
the side and don't worry about some
flash which is not just tight
one in the middle
you can get butcher's strength from your
local butcher or at cookware shops I got
two ties
go too Thai it just forces all that
stuffing out of the Lamb when it's in
the oven
nice now I want to season the top of it
roll the joint to make sure all the skin
gets seasoned
now you think normally that just goes in
the oven like that that's how my mum
would do it but get your tray onto the
gas oil in
get it really nicely colored
none of your stuffing's coming out of
the sides really important look at that
color beautiful it does kick start the
roasting process
gas off into the oven
cook for 45 to 55 minutes depending on
how pink you want your lamb
lift the lamb out of the fat to rest
resting it raised up in the tin will
stop it cooking but not cool it down too
quickly that means you won't lose any of
those lovely juices next I'm making a
simple but sophisticated accompaniment
for the lamb top and tell the Cucumber
peel it
cut the Cucumber into three and just
core taking out all that it's just sort
of watery seedium it spoils the flavor
slice the Cucumber
cucumber in
really nice way of making a cheap and
cheerful cucumber look at the Hammers
we're going to dress that cucumber with
a nice fresh yoghurt a couple of
tablespoons
next some fresh mint dress it touch of
salt
Touch of pepper
and then pomegranate molasses that just
swings it up finish that with lemon
mix that up
lamb is rested
carefully take off the string and then
just gently pull them back
straight edge knife that's going to cut
through that crispy fat on the outside
instantly I tied it purposely so I can
guess
my portion control from the lines hold
it nice and firmly look at your line
where the string was
and look
this one is going to be amazing lay and
down
just in those two slices there it proves
that stuffing Meats is for special
occasions because that is a saddle of
lamb at its absolute best
stuffing meats and fish not only makes
them look fantastic it also gives them
an extra added flavor Dimension too once
you've mastered the technique you'll be
able to turn out dishes that will
guarantee you'll have an unforgettable
Feast here are three more of my favorite
easy stuff dishes that are perfect for
any Feast
first up chicken with garlic and
Chestnut stuffing packed with flavor and
earthy richness
for the stuffing before I finely chopped
onion garlic and
celery in hot olive oil
next add pine nuts which have a lovely
creamy taste and chopped earthy cooked
chestnuts
both add a wonderfully chewy texture and
richness to stuffings season
and add chopped parsley
[Music]
then stirring cooked wild rice
next take a whole deboned chicken it's
fiddly to do at home but if you ask your
butcher will do it for you and pile the
stuffing mixture along the center now
simply roll the chicken up tightly and
tie it with your butcher's string
then roast in a hot oven for just over
an hour
simply carve into magnificent thick
slices so impressive so easy and trust
me this is a dish guaranteed to get a
fantastic reaction on any occasion
holster fish will always make an
impression my next recipe is
the bass stuffed with fennel lemon and
capers
first place a whole gutted sea bass on
foil and season the fish inside and out
sea bass is known as the king of the
Seas and has a wonderful sweet white
flesh
start the stuffing with sliced fennel
its aniseed flavor works brilliantly
with the fish
next add Capers
fresh dill
slices of lemon
then dot in knobs of butter
lastly add a splash of white wine which
helps to steam the fish and creates a
lovely sauce and seal tightly into a
parcel this locks in all the juices and
flavor
then simply bake in a medium oven
unwrap and hear your guess ooh and R
with delight prepared in 10 minutes wrap
for intense flavor a stunning sea bass
that's bound to create a stir
[Music]
my next dish throws a Spanish Twist on a
classic English roast pork stuffed with
Manchego and menbrillo
use a pork loin roasting joint
lay the joints skin side down and cut
and cut three quarters of the way into
the flesh creating space for the
stuffing
next thinly slice Spanish Manchego
cheese this has a wonderful buttery
nutty taste and is fantastic for
stuffing as it melts brilliantly
slice Spanish umbrella Queen's jelly
sweet and perfumed is the perfect
partner for the saltiness of the cheese
then simply layer your cheese and Quince
jelly into the pork
add Sage leaves for a strong and
deliciously bitter flavor
roll the meat up
and tie with butcher's string
next add more Sage leaves and some
aromatic fresh thyme to a roasting tin
then lay the pork on top skin Side Up
cut a bulb of garlic in half and wedge
it under the meat the garlic wedges help
lit the pour so it roast to Perfection
and will add a sweet depth or flavor to
your gravy
drizzle with olive oil
season and roast for just over an hour
with the heat on high for the first 20
which helps get the skin crispy and
golden
[Music]
once cooked leave the pork to rest as
you make a stunning gravy
simply Place The Roasting tin over
medium Heat
add a lug of Sherry and delays using the
roasting juices gives your gravy maximum
flavor
simmer and reduce for a few minutes then
pour in the incredible resting juices
from the pork
foreign
ly strain the silky Rich gravy over the
stuffed loin and serve immediately
through with Incredible flavor Rich
sweet and aromatic a stunning
centerpiece fit to Grace any table
anywhere anytime
three dishes stuffed to Perfection proof
you can have food that's simple to pull
off but looks incredible and tastes a
million bucks
these recipes you only need to rely on
two basic pieces of kit
don't need to spend a fortune on masses
of kitchen equipment
roasting and baking tray
these things so versatile great for
bacon whole fish on fantastic for making
breads
so cheap
a classic two-handled roasting tray
brilliant for roasting whole Birds
finishing sauces gravies on top of the
stove over the gasstring burner
again versatile
the more solid your trays are the better
then they won't buckle and they will
last cheap but seriously essential
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on I'll be
teaching you how to grab your guests
attention with an amazingly easy but
stunning starter the good news about
these wraps is that you can make them up
in advance but first my guide to getting
the best ingredients for your money
when your cooking needs to impress it
really pays to spend extra time shopping
for great ingredients and you'll reap
the rewards when it's time to serve
next up my guide to buying the finest
shellfish
whether it's scallops prawns crabs or
Lobster spanking fresh shellfish never
fails to make an impression and when you
want the best Crustaceans it pays to ask
an expert 19 bad is a bargain at 20
pounds fishmonger Roger Barton really
knows he's shellfish Inside Out hello
you see can you go back out so I'm sorry
bro if you're with me
he's been in the fish game at London's
villainsgate market for over 35 years
glean some of his knowledge and you'll
never be at a loss when it comes to
shopping for shellfish
right what we've got here are Corvettes
some people known as prawns and these
are a picture they've got to be lovely
and shiny you'll find if they're too
limp the head starts coming away from
the body
not a good sign looks a bit like me
worse for the wear shop your old garlic
up get the old Wok lovely bit of olive
oil lovely lovely jubbly lovely lovely
jubbly in my goats
absolutely fantastic
and if you like prawns as much as me
then you'll love all these different
kinds here are my favorites
Brown shrimps might be Tiny But punched
well above their weight in terms of
taste I love them potted in spice butter
and spread on toast
Atlantic prawns are great value and
packed with flavor fantastic as Tapas or
in curries
small tiger prawns are also good value
and great for Asian salads stir fries
and fish stews whereas these massive
ones are so spectacular I just keep them
simple marinated in garlic oil and chili
char grill and served in their shells
and longest things are one of my
favorites you can buy these succulent
Beauties whole just roast or boil and
serve with garlic mayonnaise
people used to eat Winkles cockles
they're not doing it anymore it's such a
shame they should be more daring all due
respect you wouldn't make love the same
way for the rest of your life
sprinkles there they are lovely they
swell of the sea little bit of pepper
and salt and a dash of vinegar with them
that does enhance the flavor
in this country we have got the finest
oysters in the world I die for these the
only thing you have to look for with an
oyster that is tightly closed if it's
open
avoid be adventurous come on try
nothing ventured nothing going get the
right recipe and the freshest shellfish
and you'll guaranteed success in the
kitchen
whether it's in one of my restaurants or
back at home I know that as well as
delicious food one of the fundamentals
to making guests happy is creating a
great atmosphere
so my next recipe where guests get to
eat with their hands is perfect for a
special occasion Vietnamese style fresh
prawn rolls one of the keys to cooking
for crowds is creating the atmosphere
and that buzz getting your guests to
sort of almost get involved and dip in
and dip out this is an exciting fragrant
wrap that is so easy to do
first off soak the noodles these are
thin glass noodles basically bring the
kettle up to the boil and just pour just
let them steep there for a couple of
minutes the noodles are for my prawn
rolls as they soak I'm gonna make a
spicy dipping sauce to go with them
start off with sugar we're trying to
create that sweet sour salty put a
really nice sort of heated sauce as well
rice wine vinegar that will dissolve the
sugar fish sauce now that's going to
give it its saltiness
next the chili I want the seeds left in
because I want some power chili in
a little bit of garlic don't need to
chop it too finely just slice it take a
spring onion just top and tell them
slice
is bringing in nice and thinly so it's
sort of almost permeates that dipping
sauce I grew up with a love of spring
rolls but on the back of my visit to
Vietnam it sort of transform my respect
for a spring roll
give that a little mix
a little bit of coriander and fresh mint
roll them up
chop
herbs in
there's no olive oil in there
there's no cream there's no butter it's
just a really nice light dipping sauce
and wow all those senses going on
now I'm gonna make the filling for the
wraps a really nice fresh noodle salad
rinse the noodles in cold water then
chop them into bite-sized lengths
prawns peeled and cooked slice them up
the prawns give a really nice sweetness
next the vegetables I want crunch
freshness texture baby gem lettuce and
just shred that lettuce
next spring onion the good news about
these wraps is that you can make them up
in advance sit them in the fridge and
then take them out literally seconds
before you get arrive
kill the cat
so you've got a really nice fresh
crunchy carrot
now fresh mint fresh basil and fresh
coriander together it sounds a little
bit bizarre but it tastes amazing don't
hold back with the herbs they'll really
help make the filling vibrant fresh and
aromatic finally touch a lime
squeeze that fresh lime juice over there
a couple of tablespoons of your dipping
sauce
don't put too much in there it just
makes all the filling too wet just give
that
a really good mix that's a very quick
simple salad to eat now but
let's get it into a wrap now take your
rice paper wrap literally 30 seconds in
warm water you can get rice paper wraps
from your local Asian supermarket or buy
them online
gently lift it out of the water there
beautiful lay it carefully onto your
board
[Music]
place the mixture
the
bottom
don't overfill it
could be a nightmare to roll
them over first nice and tightly
halfway
then tuck in the ends
make sure
nothing's coming out the sides
useful
they're so light
fragrant
incredibly simple to do
and there you go a very delicious
fragrant
Asian wrap
certainly different to the Chinese
spring rolls I grew up with
next five more of my 100 tips to help
your special occasion cooking better
kicking off with how to prepare prawns
to prep it get the head and twist
keep hold of those heads among the most
amazing stock and then with your thumb
get underneath the shell and just peel
off that beautiful little layer
now with your thumb on your finger push
and shake and look the whole tail comes
off you don't have to peel the whole
thing from there
get your knife
and just gently cut the surface of the
prawn
and what we're looking for there is that
little dirt sack that's got to come out
otherwise if you cook the prawn with
that sack in there it's crunchy it's not
very nice and it ruins that sweet flavor
and there you go the most amazing prawn
ready for cooking
rubbing whole fish always makes an
impact here's how to fillet it at the
table run a knife along the backbone
remove the skin and carefully lift off
the portions of Flesh using a fish slice
then just lift off the backbone in one
careful movement
whole hams are always impressive to
carve one easily hold the Hand by the
bone and cut down the meat as close to
the bone as possible
you can then lay your cut ham flat on
the board making it nice and easy to
slice thinly and evenly
pour crackling pour over hot oil before
roasting in the oven it'll come out
beautifully crisp and crunchy
[Music]
chill wine fast simply add a large
handful of salt to your ice bucket the
salt reduces the freezing point of the
water which will chill your wine in six
minutes flat
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stake your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking now it's time
to settle down and enjoy some slow
cooked favorites
one of the brilliant things about slow
cooking is there's often very little
preparation required and it's the oven
that does all the work
my first recipe is packed with strong
confident flavors and with the oven
taking the strain is a pleasure to make
[Music]
delicious slow braised stuffed lamb
breast
one of the secrets to slow cooking is to
be robust and really get stuck in big
bold flavors work brilliantly well so
don't be precious this is gutsy cooking
at its absolute best
these are lambres a beautiful cheap cut
and they're sort of tucked alongside the
rib they've been boned out the skin has
been taken off I'm going to roll them
stuff them and braise them braising
simply means cooking in liquid on a low
heat making the meat divinely tender now
open them up and give them a really good
seasoning season them both sides inside
and out really important it doesn't look
like a real weighty dense cut of meat
but once it's beautifully slow braised
it's just like melting lamb it's
incredible I'm going to season the
breasts with some dried oregano
put a heat in there some chili flakes
[Music]
lemon zest
[Applause]
amazing
salted anchorries in there now they
almost melt inside the lamb so the
balance of flavors work beautifully
now pull it down towards you and roll
that nice and tightly
that's what I'm looking for
a string just need to tie them three
times one at each end and one in the
middle
I fell in love with this dish years ago
when I first started working in Paris
because we had all the lamb in from the
Pyrenees
nice thing is they can be done the day
before
pan on olive oil in
get that oil nice and hot
lemon
it's really important to get some nice
color on there whilst they're Browning
slice The Onion
the lamb is going to be cooking for two
and a half hours so don't slice the
onions too thinly otherwise it'll burn
garlic and leave whole got a color on
them look at that
peaceful take them out onions in and
garlic straight in lovely
that's the secret about slow braising
you never change pans why of all the
goodness isn't that one pan
a few chili seeds in there
argano nice pinch
a little bit of lemon in there and I'll
do the onions what I did to the lamb
[Music]
next my capers
fire them off
get them exploding the bottom of the pan
they get nice and crispy next my black
olives
now
white wine
bring that up to the boil
deglazing the pan as well
a rinse in the bottom of that pan
and now the flavor in there it's just
extraordinary
now
we'll add our tomatoes
[Music]
puncher
those plum tomatoes
[Music]
then simply place the lamb breasts back
in the pot and remember to taste
[Music]
that's nice
lid on
into the oven 170.
two two and a half hours and forget
about it
whoa
beautiful
all that was reduced down to this
amazing nice
tomato sauce and the lamb
it's kept its color look at that that's
braised beautifully
very carefully
little bits there it's nice off pull off
the little bits of string
this is why I get really excited
the secret is not to slice it too thinly
look at that
smell the lemon
it's hard to believe when you slice
through the center there but that is a
very cheap cut of meat on salivating I
love this I mean it's just incredible
pick up the tomatoes and the olives and
the onions
and amazing
Rich sauce
take
your lamb sort of just
hit it on
it looks incredible
that for me
is why chefs get so excited with
cheap Cuts because the end results are
incredible
delicious breast of lamb with lemon
anchovies chili and oregano
[Music]
slow cooking is a fantastic way to
develop delicious deep flavors here are
three of my easy one pot wonders minimum
preparation long cook and an amazing
wonderful taste
first up easy ballito misto a classic
Italian mixed meat dish
[Music]
I'm starting with some Italian fennel
sausages
[Music]
fry them until colored making sure all
sides are nicely browned
set them aside then slice chorizo a
spicy Spanish sausage with a wonderful
Smoky taste and Fries so releases all
its incredible flavor
[Music]
next chop carrots
celery garlic and add to the same pan
this keeps in all the flavor
stirring the pre-lentals these are
excellent for slow cooked dishes because
they retain their firm texture and shape
next add a bay leaf and some fresh thyme
sprigs
then the sausages go back in along with
chicken stock
simmer until the lentils are tender then
season to taste
[Music]
finally sprinkle with chopped parsley
and serve simple to prepare a cinch to
make and packed full of delicious hearty
flavors my Twist on an Italian classic
magnificent easy ballito misto
[Music]
foreign
dish is slow cooked aubergine
dice the aubergine and fry in hot olive
oil until colors on all sides
then add a finely sliced onion and
chopped garlic cook until tender
cook butter beans and pomegranate
molasses which is a sweet thick and
glossy Tangy reduction of pomegranate
juice
season
[Music]
next add a can of chopped tomatoes
bring to a simmer and cook until the
aubergine has a gloriously soft and
silky texture stir through top mint pile
onto toasted bread and finally for a
lovely salty Tang crumble over some
creamy feta cheese
preparation but slow cook for maximum
flavor aubergines like you've never
tasted before
one more dish that uses time to
transform a humble ingredient is perfect
slow cooked beef
foreign
[Music]
start by frying the beef Shin in hot oil
seasoning as you go
it's a very economical cut of beef as it
slow Cooks it also makes the most
delicious gravy as the marrow thickens
and flavors the sauce
[Music]
the same pan saute chopped carrots
peeled whole shallots
sliced celery peeled and chopped ginger
and garlic
next add tomato puree and cook for a few
minutes
[Music]
add the shin back into the pan with a
glass of dry white wine
and the juice of an orange this deglazes
the pan adding incredible depth of
flavor
[Music]
pour in chicken stock season and simmer
for an hour and 20 minutes
brilliant finish with gremolata a dry
Italian salsa made with chopped herbs
simply chop parsley and garlic together
and mix in the zest of an orange or
lemon
when the beef is cooked Rich anxious and
beautifully tender scatter over the
lovely fresh gremolata
simple satisfying and crammed full of
wonderful taste and textures delicious
fast to prepare cheap and easy to make
slow cooked to Perfection three amazing
dishes I guarantee you'll make time and
time again
[Music]
this is my Essential guide to kitchen
equipment everything you need to know
about the basic kit that will get you
cooking fantastic food
casserole dish
absolutely essential when it comes to
good home cooking why so versatile the
beauty of this thing is the fact that
you can actually use it on the hob or
start it on the hob and finish in the
oven more importantly cast iron it
conducts the heat so you can have the
gas on absolute minimal or the oven down
to its absolute lowest setting and the
thing will just cook naturally casserole
dishes are surprisingly versatile and a
great investment you only need one and
if you look after it it'll last you a
lifetime
brilliant for one pot wonders welcome
back to my ultimate cookery course
I'm teaching you my slow cooked
favorites
my guide to getting the best value from
your butchers one of the biggest bills
in the kitchen is going to be for meat
so it's crucial you keep costs down but
that doesn't mean sacrificing flavor
especially when you use some slow
cooking magic to get the best from cheap
cuts to get value for money it always
pays to ask an expert and fifth
generation award-winning Master butcher
Danny lidgate is a man in the know one
of the great things about going to a
butcher is they're going to have more
Cuts available than most supermarkets so
you're going to see things that people
don't know about so one example might be
the beef ribs a great product for slow
cooking in the oven especially cooking
on the bone you're going to get more
flavors from the bone there's some
really nice pieces of Juicy meat these
only used for mince in the past now
people are using it for braising or slow
braising or even barbecuing it with some
really nice marinades the oxtail are
less popular now than maybe they used to
be small little mussels make up the tail
once that's slow cooked they all fall
apart really tender juicy Meats also
oxtail is Sublime en stews curries and
soups another great cheap cut for slow
cooking is one you saw me using earlier
Lamb's breast
[Music]
is one of the least expensive cuts of
lamb and it's also delicious slow
roasted or stewed here we have the shin
of beef you can see
in the sheds made up lots of little
different mussels these are always
moving always doing work so slow cooking
will give the best end results it's
going to have fashion a little bit but
it should be enjoyed by everybody it's a
fantastic piece of meat here we have
some ox cheeks and when they're trimmed
you end up with a really lean piece of
meat obviously with the cheek the cow's
always eating munching on grass this
means I need a lot of cooking but
essentially it's a really nice healthy
lean piece of meat with fantastic
flavors
oxchicks also make an incredible ravioli
or Ragu and if you're a pork lover why
not try pork neck it's a succulent
alternative for a slow Sunday roast here
we have a muscle from the shoulder it's
called feather blades
the reason it's called feather blade is
because when it's cut
each piece looks like a feather the
gristle tends to be slow cooked and the
more it's cooked we'll turn gelatinous
giving a lovely jelly and juicy liquid
to the meat fantastic for casserole pies
and stews there are so many cheaper cuts
which are brilliant for home cooking
it's important with all these forgotten
cuts to find out how to cook them don't
be scared of them they're really
economic but full of flavor and the end
result is fantastic meal
as a chef one of the biggest kicks I get
is taking an ingredient that doesn't
cost much and turning into something
that looks and tastes like a million
bucks
my next recipe turns what used to be a
decidedly unfashionable cut of meat into
the star of the dish fit to Grace any
table
slow roasted pork belly with fennel
slow roasting works better on fattier
tougher and unfashionable cuts whether
it's a cheek or even a neck or this
amazing pork belly it's a fantastic way
to transform cheap cuts into amazing
melting perfection
take a very sharp knife bring the pork
belly towards you so you're over it
you've got all that pressure and weight
using the tip of the knife I'm just sort
of nicking it I go across the pork belly
long strokes with a knife take your time
turn it 180 this time what we're doing
is just sort of cutting those nice
little sort of diamonds but as that
starts roasting on top it starts to get
nice and crispy
take your handfuls of salt and just sort
of rub it in bend it over and then all
those cracks really helps to get a nice
crisp crackling on top
roasting tray
getting really nice and hot
take a hole over fennel to intensify
flavor and to keep the meat succulent
I'm braising my pork belly with strong
vibrant spices and vegetables
crush and peel three whole cloves of
garlic and add to the fennel olive oil
in
fennel in
I like the nice strong aniseed flavor
that goes with that nice rich dense pork
fennel seeds delicious
Taiwanese in
and just
a couple of cardamom seeds
and wow they're like little bangers like
little firecrackers incredible
lovely
fresh bay leaves
get your pork skin side down
just sear the top of that fat that locks
in all that amazing flavor then I'm
gonna flip it over and get it nice and
crispy
and then on fennel seeds embedded in
those little cracks
now some white wine
the minute that white wine hits that pan
you can just smell that light fragrance
and the fennel
allow the wine to Bubble away and reduce
until the alcohol is burnt off sometimes
at the stock NOW the stock goes in just
underneath the skin so it roasts on top
all that meat under there it's gonna be
submerged because what happens in the
oven the top goes crispy as anything
and the stock reduces and braises at the
same time
really importantly bring that back up to
the ball before it goes in the oven
otherwise it will never boil never go up
to temperature
smells incredible
slow roasted pork belly at 180 degrees
for two and a half hours
[Music]
look at that you've got that nice crispy
skin on top
you can see how much of the stock has
evaporated
put that onto the board it looks
stunning
to make a delicious rustic sauce with
the flavor packed contents of the
roasting tray first get rid of the
excess fat take a couple of slices of
bread it's like a perfect sponge because
you just lay that
on top
and drag it almost like a net and it
just absorbs all that fat if you want
the perfect fried bread trust me stick
that in a frying pan
a nice teaspoon of mustard whisk that in
and then simply simmer for a few minutes
before pouring into a serving jug
with your pork belly always use a nice
serrated edge knife
you can hear that
wow
that is amazing incredibly tender
that belly of pork is gonna almost melt
in your mouth you've got that sweet meat
under that crispy belly of pork what an
amazing way to cook a very cheap cut of
meat
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
kitchen tips
first how to make a fantastic chicken
stock a classic slow cook recipe that
gets amazing flavor from simple
ingredients
chicken stock
ingredient to good cooking it trans
sources it's a fantastic base for Soups
and more importantly it's so easy to do
a little bit of love and care at the
beginning and it Cooks itself right step
one chicken carcass into a pie sided pan
an onion
does need to be finely chopped the
vegetables flavor the stock
onion in
then from there cut your leek into nice
big solid chunks roughly
same size as the onion
silver vegetables cook at the same time
and then add carrots
celery and garlic
and then a nice
sprig of thyme that helps to really give
depth of flavor to the chicken stock a
couple of bay leaves
and some fresh parsley
and then peppercorns pan and just
lightly crush them
and a little pinch of salt
and now just cover the vegetables and
the carcass with cold water
just cover the chicken and the
vegetables
bring it up to the ball as quick as you
can
now as it comes into the boil a really
nice skin take the base of a ladle and
swirl that around that pushes all the
grease and the impurities to the side of
the pan then get your Laden and just
tilt it
if you don't skim all that off the stock
becomes very cloudy
people's impression of cooking stock
then it needs to cook for three four
hours at a time this is one chicken
carcass let that boil away gently for 30
to 40 minutes maximum
we're gonna pass it off
let's take a sieve
place that over
the pan
and then just
pour that in
it smells amazing it's aromatic
the color is absolutely beautiful
from there you have
the most amazing stock
when you need to season meat in flour a
great tip is to place it in a plastic
bag to dust it evenly using flour also
helps the sauce to get nice and thick
during cooking
when Browning meat fry in small batches
don't crowd the pan otherwise it won't
sear or color properly
when slow roasting meat line the bottom
of the roasting tray with chunky
vegetables like onions fennel and
carrots they act as a trivet to keep the
meat from boiling in its own juices plus
the veg can be the base for your gravy
later on
after slow cooking baked on residue can
be tough to remove but if you boil water
in the pan it will dissolve and break
down then simply pour out and wash with
soap and water
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to stay your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking